liquid death so cut we we tweeted out
and we put in the Facebook group hey
what should we talk about this week and
a bunch of people mentioned hey what do
you thing about liquid death and so they
just raised a round of funding so what
is liquid death it's a canned water so
not like Lacroix or whatever it is the
look of it is like heavy metal so it's
it's basically just a canned water drink
but they went all in on the brand it's
made by these guys out in LA the
incubator science and they're behind
things like Dollar Shave Club and
wishbone this like teen app and a bunch
of other things are an incubator studio
out there and the guys who started it
Mike and Peter are interesting stories
are in our internet bedroom Mike was
like CEO of MySpace and Peter I think
photobucket I think is kind of claim to
fame Peter Pham and so anyways they're
interesting crew and they came out you
know the sort of bottled water or canned
water market is actually pretty huge now
and they just wanted to come out with a
different angle so they're like look how
you know how the hell do you gonna sell
water well you have to create a brand
and a story around it in almost a use
case and so the thing they wanted to do
was sort of you know in many social
situations when you grab water you're
opting out of like the fun of the social
thing you know if you're at a bar or if
you had a festival or something like
that so they wanted to make a can that
looks cool feels cool is something worth
talking about
and it's just like you you know you're
having a drink of some kind
[Music]
you